[Musique]
quand les éjaculations commence-t-elle
pourquoi y at il des savoirs de condom
voici de vraies questions posées dans
une classe de secondaire iii c'est quoi
le placenta
c'est quoi la taille moyenne d'un pénis
c'est souvent des questions par rapport
à la normalité est ce que c'est normal
de est-ce que je suis normal si c'est
souvent pareil les jeunes veulent
valider dans ces questions là les jeunes
sont exposés à une multitude de facettes
de la sexualité des relations pas
toujours très saine
lorsque vu à travers les médias sociaux
ou à travers des sites internet de
pornographie l'éducation à la sexualité
permet de faire contrepoids à tout ce
cette information là qu'ils ont pour
première toute cette désinformation
l'eau qu'ils ont l'érablière est une des
rares écoles secondaires au québec avoir
accepté d'implanter le projet pilote
nous sommes ici en milieu rural blanc
homogène qui rayonne à 14 ans elle est
une élève de secondaire 2 de davos n'a
jamais dit qu'un son père serge gendron
comme l'ensemble des parents de l'école
approuvent la décision de la direction
d'intégrer les cours d'éducation à la
sexualité
il y en a eu des places que ce tango
tabou même nom rockeur pas d'audace au
psg car cachés cash-ebit fait que
l'enfant va prendre comme un instant sur
internet tu peux tout te prends mais y
l'école secondaire de saint félix de
valois avait une longueur d'avancé
la direction avait toujours maintenu une
partie de l'enseignement aux sexualités
en accord avec la communauté un art 25
qui décide de participer à un concours
de beauté
j'ai ciblé des enseignants qui ont un
bon lien avec les élèves à qui les élève
on est à l'aise de se confier des gens
qui ont une belle ouverture d'esprit
marc l'objet éthique et culture
religieuse 4e et 5e secondaire charline
meyer amour enseignant de sciences au
secondaire
geneviève beaudry enseignante de
français 2e secondaire celle là gagne ce
matin on avait absolument rien et donc
tout était à créer on devait choisir ce
qu'on avait envie de faire
moi c'est certain que bompard la
littérature je trouvais que c'était une
bonne idée on ne monte un questionnaire
on a choisi des extraits dans un roman
très original on apprenait ainsi au
moral c'est une première moi j'ai pas
aimé ça ne pouvoir voir ce pauvre parce
que moi j'en ai jamais vécu
personnellement c'est quand qu'on tombe
en coupe on tente pas nécessairement
avec un jt m6 y plusieurs phases
d'apprentissage je te trouve beau après
ce j'apprends à connaître ex utero pot
tous deux souhaitaient faire campagne
aux primaires les je t'aime tous une
pièce ça m'a permis de comprendre qui
ont aidé en plusieurs phases a à faire
pour avoir une bonne relation
on avait des passages où est-ce qu'ils
avaient plus de violence on sait que
c'est pas acceptant puis qu'on devrait
pas tolérer stock canton une relation
amoureuse peu importe qu'elle soit
verbale physique
geneviève et ses collègues ont bâti
elles-mêmes leurs cours avec les pluies
de ressources spécialisées
un jeune qui il se demande si unités à 6
à sa demande cette enceinte avec une
agression sexuelle à sait pas trop si
c'est la violence qu'a vie ou sepa sont
pas disposés à l'apprentissage qui sont
en détresse et je ne veux donc comment
ils peuvent enseigner des matchs ou du
français dans un contexte comme cela
deco qui donne ce ça peut pas être
mauvais c'est impossible de soi mauvais
si je trouve ça important nous en avait
pas qui est aux autres la possibilité
d'avoir ce je trouve ça merveilleux sa
publicité là il ya des gens nous
regardent
le projet pilote prévoit que des
professionnels à bord de l'iss sujets
délicats comme la violence dans le
couple les maladies vénériennes où les
abus sexuels mais tout le reste est
intégré aux cours que donne
habituellement les enseignants fait
référence au tao côté affectif au côté
psychologique aux comptes et culturel au
côté social les lois et autres il ya pas
une notion qui ne connaissent pas est ce
que vous trouvez que c'est trop oui
pourquoi non pourquoi tient probablement
déjà confronté si je vous disais que ces
vaccins d'être capable de mettre leurs
limites et capable dans charlie ne pas
arriver dans des situations où il est
trop tard pour beaucoup dans la réussite
est cerné communes prêtes à faire des
choses avant d'autres ça me faisait
écouter vous le dire respecter les
autres
testez terme en sept parties le de trop
parce que toi tu veux le faire que toi
tu es prête à faire ce que l'autre
personne est nécessairement prête et
copies soit sauf de l'oci est d'accord
au moment où vous allez franchir une
étape c'est de les outiller davantage le
bus promis fait capable de se
questionner une capable de questionner
les autres est capable d'en parler
ouvertement la sexualité aussi pas
toujours justes à la blague pas toujours
en dérision
parce qu'on peut dire
c'est sûr que les pressions de la
société l'un des études ont affamé
toussaint que se passe-t-il si un gars
éjacule dans un autre est ce qu'on peut
faire l'amour pendant les menstruations
on veut pas savoir les expériences
réelles des jeunes gens pour savoir ce
qu'ils ont fait leur fin de semaine
passée établi dès le début y a pas de
mauvaises questions on répond avec des
bons termes on veut pas banaliser n'ont
plus aucune question on voit répondre
aux questions certains parents peuvent
craindre que ces cours et des effets
négatifs
l'ensemble des études sont assez
catégorique le fait de parler de
sexualité aux jeunes les instits
aucunement à avoir des relations
sexuelles
les jeunes au contraire qu'ils
bénéficient d'une éducation sexuelle ont
des rapports sexuels davantage protégé
donc qu'ils utilisent davantage de
condom la contraception à l'amitié au
moins deux partenaires qui s'engagent
dans des activités sexuelles avec
lesquels ils sont plus confortables et
consenti l'éducation à la sexualité est
aussi un moyen efficace de lutter contre
les heat et ss les infections transmises
sexuellement et par le sang c'est que
présentement une véritable épidémie
frappe les jeunes âgés entre 15 et 24
ans de partout québec
ils sont particulièrement touchés par la
chlamydia et la gonorrhée une
problématique évidemment incluse dans le
projet pilote j'avais dit que a trouvé
que c'était un corps humain extrême ici
voici ce qu'on n'était pas au courant de
chaque balle comme nous faire nous faire
allumer el fath en santé j'ai ça peut
être dangereux sans nécessairement à la
même façon que ici sinon comme deux
façons de protéger différents
le projet pilote sera évalué au cours de
la prochaine année
mais pour les parents de kyrian leur
enseignement appuyé par celui de l'école
porte déjà fruits j'aime bien varna
beaucoup élaboré sur suivi les étapes
allait pas trop vite puis c'est ce que
j'ai retenu le plus parce que c'est
facile aux parements le site so 2 je
trouve tout son sens rassemble le thé ou
un nouveau coup de protéger pour paca se
passe mal c'est papa il me protégerait
le ces quelques heures difficiles
[Musique]